bonjour antoine la sentence est donc
tombé dans cette affaire d'espionnage
qui vient de nouveau trouvé les
relations russo américaines
oui 16 ans de prison pour espionnage
contre paul willan cet ancien marine
américano britannique qui a également la
nationalité canadienne et irlandaise
l'inculpé qui était présent à l'audience
a tout de suite dénoncé je cite un
simulacre de procès et annoncé vouloir
faire appel de cette décision de justice
alors il a été arrêté en 2018 à moscou
alors qu'ils assistaient à un mariage
ils étaient en possession d'après les
services de sécurité russes d'une clé
usb contenant des données
confidentielles de son côté lui estime
être victime d'une machination d'un
piège et c'est une affaire de plus qui
vient empoisonner encore davantage les
relations entre la russie et les etats
unis l'ambassadeur américain en poste à
moscou à d'ores et déjà réagi à cette
affaire je vous propose de l'écouter
comme vous le savez je suis de près le
cas de paul depuis mon arrivée ici en
tant qu'ambassadeur en janvier j'ai
décrit ces procédures comme une moquerie
de la justice et aujourd'hui on vient de
le confirmer
un citoyen américain a été condamné à
une peine de 16 ans pour un crime pour
lequel nous n'avons pas vu de preuve le
porte le porte-parole du kremlin dimitri
peskov à lui également commenter cette
affaire cette décision de justice vous
propose de l'écouter le kremlin ne
s'occupe pas de telles questions
dans ce cas concret je ne commente en
aucune façon la décision de la justice
et cette situation en particulier il a
été condamné par le tribunal et la
décision du tribunal dit où il a été
inculpé et ces accusations ont été
prouvées devant le tribunal est
confirmée par le tribunal comme dans
toutes les affaires d'espionnage
difficile de démêler le vrai du faux
c'est parole contre parole et en croire
l'avocat de paul willan on s'orienterait
vers un échange de prisonniers entre la
russie et les etats unis une possibilité
que les autorités russes n'ont pas
écarté
merci beaucoup en tant que l'hérault
depuis moscou